so we have a first base coach for the
day alan trammell is joining the staff
for today trammell certainly tiger fans
know who he is and love him so jack
flaherty gets the call this afternoon
for st louis cardinals once again facing
a situation where you want these
starters any day you want them to go
deep but when you have a double header
and another one next week and then
another one you got to get length 23
games in 18 days and as we said in the
open no more off days reyes at the plate
swag and a miss and a strikeout that's
how we start the afternoon a strikeout
for jack flaherty here to bring in
jonathan
and he struck him out back-to-back case
to start his afternoon and it brings in
miguel cabrera swinging a miss and he
strikes out the side it's reyes scope
and cabrera one two three all strikeouts
today's starting pitcher is terric scuba
first career appearance against the
cardinals this is his fourth start on
the road standing in now the cardinal
the first baseman paul goldsmith
swinging a miss fastball got him that's
a good first inning for terek scuba that
ball plays up man
and you do not have to adjust your
television set he is in fact wearing at
number 21 today honored i think is the
best word to describe what it's like to
represent roberto clemente and his
legacy
and a fly ball lifted out to deep left
field it's at the wrong
gone
yadier molina on a day in which he's
wearing number 21
homer's roberto clemente day
and you know it's extra special for him
to run homer yachty two-nothing st louis
you know that means something extra
special to him nothing stoic about that
trip around the bases
for number 21 yadier molini that's
awesome oh that's the joy of sports too
isn't it runners at the corners two line
drive singles here in the third and the
tigers have something brewing with one
out with scope and cabrera coming up and
the pitch is hit up the middle long back
hands he'll step on the bag double play
did he stay on no off the bag and the
run will score
and the cardinals want to look at it
and he's out oh he's on the bag there
yeah and it is a double play the play is
overturned so no run the cardinals have
the lead off man on edmond hit a fly
ball to center field for an out in the
first inning a swing and the balls hit
down the left field line that's going to
get down and go all the way to the wall
wong may score he rounds third base the
ball gets away from demerit and stopping
at second with an rbi double it's tommy
edmund and the cardinals lead three
nothing tommy edmund coming through this
is a high off speed pitch and
tommy just
jumped on it
and that ball took a long time to get
out of the corner in left field for some
reason and there's the reason either way
colton wong was going to score that's
four walks for scuba d young at the
plate swing and a ground ball headed up
the middle of base it to center field
around third tommy edmond is going to
score streaking to third baseball
goldschmidt the cardinals lead four to
nothing they can pay for those walks as
who come after rondell ravello first and
third nobody out two runs in a swing and
a fly ball that's it well deep left
center and it is caught over the
shoulder by travis demerit tagging at
third goldsmith scores it's a sacrifice
fly for ravello five nothing cardinals
in the third he's trying to keep the
line moving o'neal the seventh batter of
the third inning
o'neill hits it to left field
two-run homer tyler o'neill
fifth home run of the season for o'neal
seven nothing cardinals and the lion
keeps on moving and that gets wayne
thomas to the plate there's a swing and
a fly ball left field that sends demerit
back and the ball's gone it goes over
the wall into the tiger bullpen a
two-run homer for lane thomas
and it's a nine-nothing cardinal lead in
the third as the cardinals have banned
it around against the detroit tigers
over at first base with the lead hit
brings up jamer candelario swings and
hits a high fly ball down the right
field line into the corner thomas at the
fence looking up and it's gone a home
run
chamber candelario has been one of the
bright spots this year
two run shot tigers are on the board
trailing nine to two colts met a
strikeout and a walk for the run scored
and goldsmith
sends one to center
it's at the wall that's gone four home
runs hit by the cardinals here in game
one and number five on the year for the
cardinal first baseman so four home runs
today the most recent this one on his
birthday
and that's lifted down the left field
line near the foul pole
gone
five home runs hit by the cardinals
today
this one
ron hell ravelo
and again a two run homer
for it he's uh we'll bat now he's
singled and scored and flied to right
and chopped to colt wong and that will
be
a game one win for st louis in this
double header the cardinals now 19 and
17 on the year